hello and welcome to a new edition
of las vegas spanish side of health to
natalia bad had today we kick off
our weekend with a new
song by former
las vegas resident jennifer lopez
[Music]
the new song from  yale together with
alejandro is called cambia el paso and it is
available on all music platforms
including youtube well and the
music continues to arrive in las vegas and
this time with a great announcement
by one of the musical icons
by the  darlings we're back ella
mclean backstreet boys
and life nuisance nsync action and one
volume loves are hanging out for days
gearing up for a new project coming to
the nation resort this august last month
i sat down exclusively with her
to talk about it
on transgression now  at airport
and will be in las vegas from august 19 to 22
tickets for this show go
on sale on the morning of july 10 at
ticketmaster.com when  When we now change the subject and
talk about another kind of
entertainment and that is that the opinion show
will take the stage again within
the cosmopolitan after a 15-
month hiatus due to the pandemic
the first will take place on September 24
tickets for that event are already
available
good  and if you prefer to enjoy the
local entertainment in the open air,
mandalay bay offers you its series of
concerts on the beach, dwight yoakam will
perform this Friday, July 9,
while on August 28 the group
caifanes will take the stage and on
September 18 the group bronco  will celebrate
mexican independence day to
buy your hub and full list
of artists visit mandalay bay
dotcom
well what i did you are trying to
maximize your fun but
without spending a lot of money well here is
a solution down
and blocks concert series from  freeman suite is already in
full effect with free shows
on weekends
dwayne watch and twin white  rather cheese
will be presented on saturday july 17
steven adler from guns and roses on
august 21 and twitters down on september 5
obviously you can find the
complete list of artists at
vegas experience dotcom well and this
friday the star bruno mars will be
presented  in the park too with two
shows on friday and saturday and two other
shows on july 23 and 24 tickets for
this weekend and they are sold out but
you can still get it for the other
shows at the end of the month just visit
ticketmaster.com
when it arrived  It's time to laugh non-stop
because after this pandemic I think we
all know that we need
a laugh or two and what better way to
do it than with the geniuses of
comedy or cesop comer and this
weekend from comedian chelsea handler
take the stage of the mirage and at the end of the
month this comedian will go through
las vegas'
portland
[Laughter]
well you'll be able to see gabriel iglesias on the
22nd, 23rd and 24th that's the aggressive comedian  he won
two dates due to high
fan demand you will also see davis paste and
baile
weiser george lopez and many
more comedians and he will also be performing at the
anniversary this summer for a
complete list of all the
comedians from this event and for  buy
your sit-ins visit mirage dotcom
well here came your las
vegas nao edition in spanish see
you next week greets you natalia balseiro
[Music]